and first of all it's patrick corbin
four and one career against miami
the marlins are going for win number
2000 in club history tonight
and he has him reaching
unable to reach it
0-2 look like a swing
chris siegel confirms ron culpa's call
at home plate
two down
swaying and a miss
busting him inside with the fastball hey
what's up with this corbin heater so far
two strikeouts on the heater just one on
the slider in the first eliezer
hernandez taking on the nationals
tonight two balls and two strikes from
eliezer hernandez and a swing and a miss
so a good first inning for hernandez one
two three
and he battles back to strike him out
corbin's fastball with some sinking
action
his strikeout pitch so far that's number
four two down now and it'll be up to
miguel rojas
and on 2-0
he hits a high fly ball that goes deep
to left field soto turns around and
welcome back miguel rojas
three-run home run and the marlins are
on the board
yeah you've been gone too long and boy
did we miss you
but here he swings and misses and that's
the second strikeout for eliezer
hernandez
so two out of nobody on and john gomez
the batter home's a five-game hitting
streak
and gomes will launch one high in the
air deep right center brinson back see
you
later and the nats have two homers from
their catchers as gomes gets his first
like kurt suzuki did earlier
career marked their number 100 of his
big league career there goes the shutout
now we dance on one swing
you have hitters that are a little bit
more cautious because of the slacker
ella called strike three thames didn't
like it
[Applause]
there's an umpire with one of the
quicker triggers in baseball had a meet
long run he's going to get there and
that was a fair ball when he caught it
well done two outs
wouldn't doubt slide just in case that
little points coming at you nice play by
adam eaton on the blue pop-up down the
right field line
trey turner ground ball to short first
time
and that ball is touched loud sound deep
right center
see
you later
and that's not a bad start to the second
time around the order
3-2 ball game yeah the talking down
there
just got to be so careful
that fastball was up it beats eaton but
the gnats get one back
has been 9-1-8 so keep it close and you
feel like you got a chance
well he takes care of brinson who walked
first time what's working and what's not
utilizing what's going best and then
he'll slide that one away
that might be his best slider yet
castro out for the year and garcia out
for this at-bat five strikeouts for
hernandez
tap her left side kibum on the move
little trouble with the exchange but he
still had time
to throw out the big fella aguilar two
down
he had the time for the double clutch
with aguilar running
and key boom throws him out for the
second out here at the top of the fifth
inning
nasty slider that's how you end an
inning with a pitch like that corbin
through five has settled in
may have gotten away with one right
there he'll take it six strikeouts
[Applause]
great slider by corbin not giving in on
a 3-2 fastball strikeout number eight
his 30th of the year two balls two
strikes
he's going to ring him up with a high
fastball strikeout number nine
eaton soto and cabrera coming up against
stephen tarpley
and a called strike three goes to the
breaking ball got just enough of the
zone to freeze adam eaton
tarpley's 2-2 pitch and he gets some
swinging back-to-back strikeouts
since coming into the game two away in
the sixth
one and two
and gets some swing and gets away from
cervelli
that's gonna do it i guess
no need to complete the strikeout one on
one out in a one-run game and that one
is ripped fair down toward the corner
rojas is heading toward third he will
get held up right there
on a double by jonathan vr so second and
third one out
zacular has never faced tanner rainey
who makes his 11th appearance
see another payoff pitch
and the marlins will have the bases
loaded
swing and a miss on 97
for out number two huge strikeout
into left soto is there
right at him who's better in set up and
hold him
than tanner rainey right now
[Applause]
james hoyt into the game here it is
swing and a miss
hoyt comes in gets the job done strands
a couple and protects the marlins one
run lead as we go to the eighth
2-2
ground ball
and the guy who provides the offense
ends the night it's a marlins win miguel
rojas makes the play he hit the
three-run home run early in the game on
the first pitch he saw off the il
and that was all the marlins needed in
this one